was soll das jetzt das machst du da was
machen kaffee wenn sie sich fortpflanzen
wollen leute jetzt in kurzen videos und
eine gewisse zeit vergangen seit meinem
letzten hilfe mehr video ich würde sagen
es wird wieder zeit und ganz besonders
wird dieser an dass es zeit wird weil
ihr liebe zuschauer mir ein video zu
geschickt dass mir anschauen sollte was
wirklich einfach nicht okay ist
es ist einfach nicht okay oder wird
sollte dieses video ist wirklich einfach
geisteskranke abstoßen die kommt schon
alleine von selbst drauf ihr euch den
titel anschaut so das video heißt
einfach gibt pfötchen meine freundin
denkt sie ist eine katze und damit ist
eigentlich relativ viel gesagt über das
video in welche richtung es geht aber es
ist noch nicht genug dazu gesagt wie
schlimm dieses video eigentlich wirklich
ist und deswegen schauen wir uns das
jetzt an
das soll es jetzt
ddp sonst nicht hat kann auf die
schnauze
ich begebe mich jetzt eine wohnung ist
reich ist vielleicht jetzt schon zehn
sekunden sind von diesem video bisher
gespielt und schon kann man diese videos
sieht die ich immer sehr da brauchen
wirklich bau wirklich starke nerven
ihr seht schon welche richtung das geht
aber ich will euch zu vorschnellen
urteil hatte wir schauen ein bisschen
weiter das sollte es jetzt das machst du
da das nachdem kassiererin sich
fortpflanzen wollen du bist aber keine
katze schätzchen du bist ein
menschliches wesen ok homo sapiens
kapiert ja für dein persönliches
verhalten ist es relativ egal was sind
vierbeinige lebewesen okay machen wenn
sie sich fortpflanzen du bist keine
katze du glaubst das macht mich jetzt an
dass ich jetzt ans fortpflanzen denke
was sowohl den schuss nicht gehört wenn
du mal endlich auch mit diesem katzen
filme
leute und ich glaube nicht viele dinge
die ich in meinem leben gesehen habe
waren trauriger ist dieses fauchen
gewaltiger was zur hölle ist dass man
was das pärchen hallo at 24 bisschen
irgendwie mal so einen einstieg haben
irgendwie so ein bisschen herangeführt
werden müsst ihr uns gleich nur die
fucking fleischwurst direkt ins gesicht
klatschen das ist wirklich 28 sekunden
in die video und das ist eigentlich
schon komplett vorbei ich habe keinen
bock auf bekannte ich will eine frau und
hör auf mich irgendwelche balztanz
sofort zu tanzen ich versteh gar nicht
was du hast ne versteh's nicht was er
hat ich habe da ich habe keinen bock
drauf leute hatten sie doch total
niedlich und ich dachte du stehst du
bist aber keine katze und ich stehe ich
auch so ein blödsinn
ohne wird es ist wirklich so dass was
man die sache erstmal diesen ganzen rtl2
zeugen und auch einmalig eine andere
videos die wir so sehen auf diesem kanal
es ist einfach immer eine mischung aus
lachen und weinen okay ich war gebt euch
mal was wir gerade im gesehen haben okay
wir sind nicht mal eine minute in diesem
video dann werde ich dieses spricht er
von dieser jungen frau die von
irgendwann der produktionsfirma von rtl2
angefragt wurde konnte er gesagt oder so
hey willst du mal im fernsehen
schauspieler also das ist dabei
rausgekommen ich hab keinen bock auf
dieses mal wäre doch mal endlich normal
es regt mich mehr auf jetzt wisst ihr
was ich am meisten schockiert in dieser
szene so gibt euch einen
gesichtsausdruck sie hat einfach
überhaupt kein verständnis dafür dass er
darauf keinen bock hat dieser
das kann ernst dass gerade in ernst dass
das nicht attraktiv finde ist dass ich
denke dass ich ein fucking haustier bin
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich allen ernstes relativ
gespannt leute wie rtl2 das retten will
bzw die rtl 2 das erst mal eine tolle
partie
also hilfe folgen brauchen wir mal so
dass am anfang irgendwas geisteskrank es
passiert und dann im laufe der folge
wird normalerweise so erklärt warum das
passiert ist was passiert ist warum
leute sich so komisch verhalten
wir wollen die das erklären ganz im
ernst verstehe auch nicht was los mit
dir dass die so komisch und und setzte
so seine katzen hat der macht mich
völlig wahnsinnig leute kurzer blick in
die kommentare zeigt es auch schon
vorgekommen sind top kommentar als
einfach hier ist der schlimmer geht es
nicht mehr button ich glaube da kann man
schon mal leichter lassen ja sehr
dahinter ausgestreckt wollte sich dann
in japan total durchgeknallt oder ich
verstehe auch nicht wieso sie sich jetzt
so krass verändert hat sie ja ohne
virtuelle aufgabe ist in der szene so
ein sonstiges tag über seine beziehung
zu machen
man sieht ihm so an das jetzt so
kurzfristig komme dann ab zu lachen wie
oft haben sie diese szene gedreht safe
zu 20-mal ich verstehe auch nicht wieso
sie sich jetzt so krass verändert hat
der brüder glücklich wieder zum laufen
wird
seitdem sie arbeitslos ist ist sie so
komisch und seltsam drauf aber so sie
sich wie eine katze benimmt ist verstehe
ich echt nicht okay der grund dafür dass
sie sich für eine katze hält ist dass
sie arbeitslos ist das macht natürlich
sinn rtl2 das ist wirklich eine gute
herleitung kurze google suche zeigt dass
wir aktuell in deutschland 2,31
millionen arbeitslose haben das heißt
auf 2,31 millionen katzen menschen ja
das ist dass das was hier und sagen
wollte erzählt zeit ist es ja irgendwie
so eine verspätete hello kitty phase
oder so nein
hallo die braut ist geisteskrank das
anders hat sich so ein hello kitty
heftig mit in die schule zu nehmen oder
kanaren hello kitty sticker überall hin
zu kleben oder in hello kitty bettwäsche
schlafen okay was hier abgeht ist
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
wir gucken was wir machen können nee nee
nee da sollte ich will auch nicht bei
jeder szene aus meinem zimmer rausgehen
aber ich hätte zwei das ist wirklich das
ist traurig dem haben die scheiße das
aussieht recht so viel geben und muss
ich wieder im minirock zu sehen
ok also sie schmeißen gerade so ihre
klamotten welt was safe nicht darin
enden wird dass die katzenfrau und
mentalen breakdown hat auf gar keinen
fall die wird damit gut umgehen können
und sich danach ändern damit alles wohl
okay sie um gerade den schminktisch
ausgeräumt und dann kommt auf einmal die
experten rein und sagt irgendwas und die
experte hat auch einen hund auf dem
schoß warum wenn raffael an ihrer katzen
existenz lebt wird sich daran auch
nichts ändern wenn ladiner und paco ihre
kostüme wegwerfen
es könnte sogar sein dass diese offene
ablehnung ihr verhalten noch weiter
verstärkt ok warum hast du ein hund auf
dem schoß sorry falls ich nachfrage aber
sagt da niemand was dazu warum ist
dieser unter was für das jetzt hier sag
mal was macht ihr mit meinen sachen ihr
habt uns etwa es ist nicht euer ernst
oder jetzt leute man sieht eben so
richtig annehmen geht es genauso wie mir
man sieht ihm so richtig an wir einfach
so mit der situation struggled es ist
wirklich schwer für ihn damit zu spielen
bittet haben wir eure meinung mit leuten
aber wenn ihr diese szenen hier so sehen
ist es nicht so dass ist nicht so wie
normalerweise bei hilf mir wo man sich
so denkt zwar voll dumm sondern es ist
so man denkt sich so das zieht mich
irgendwie herunter
es ist einfach so absurd so das stört
komplett meine realität verändert und
ich beruhige mich überhaupt nicht suchen
unserer verringert zurück
raphaela vielleicht mal kurz einen blick
in den spiegel werfen
ja du hast katzenohren auch im
karnevalskostüm an du bist geschminkt
wie an karneval bitte jetzt ergreift die
nötigen konsequenzen und weiß sich
selbst in die irre man schon ein
einschub es mir jetzt sofort meine
sachen zurück das kann man nicht ein
ernstes thema von peter freut sich von
dir also das ist deutsches fernsehen
was das macht eher zurückgehen das wir
ist deutsches fernsehen das ist das was
in deutschland läuft in einem medium
muss man sagen was millionen von
menschen tagtäglich sehen rtl 2 ist auch
im kleinen sender besticht und safe
millionen von leuten das wollte ich die
fernsehsender ohne wird sollte also mir
fehlen mir fehlen ein bisschen die worte
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
denn der schock ist groß berichtet ok
oder dem freund ist auch nicht geistig
gestörten denke werden im tier- komma
klar alter was ist das guck dich doch
mal selbst angucken was du dafür der
falcon kapuze auf der welt was soll das
sein alter sieht aus wie die katze aus
alice im wunderland okay aber das ist
nicht alles im wunderland das ist das
echte leben kannst du nie wieder
anziehen wie sieht es dann aus schon so
ein zeug schaut euch wirklich
okay wir versuchen die sachen
wegzuwerfen scheinbar ist das problem
nicht so einfach zu lösen
[Musik]
leute das kann kein zufall sein
es kann kein zufall sein rtl 2 das ist
wirklich eine geile botschaft das habt
ihr gut platziert ja ok hab grad eben
diese aufnahmen gesehen dieses mädchen
hat dann wieder so auf ihrem ich weiß
nicht was sitzplatz oder so und dann
kommt der freund rein und gebt euch
dieses plakat was auch der tür ist das
ist die zusammenfassung ihren los dieses
video ist ehren los es ist er los schaut
schaut euch das an die so so sitzt da
wie ein penner in der ecke rum was wir
weiter er hat sich so übels verwandelt
der gerade eben noch so ihr appell wir
müssen irgendwas machen ich glaube er
hat irgendwann sowieso gut realisiert
was macht keinen sinn
wir haben ein sofa da kannst du dich
hinsetzen
hast du schon mal eine katze gesehen die
auf der couch sitzt vernünftig es kann
nicht sein das ist keine schau ich
brauche dieses poster ehren los junge
und dem album kommst hier nicht rein
ich glaube ich weiß was da abgeht rtl2
hat so ich gedacht höheren wertverlust
sich wenn sie so in seinen klub
reingehen haben dann einfach vor so
einer stinknormalen haustür einfach zu
den roten teppich ausgerollt haben
irgendeine andere jungen menschen der
auch so ein bisschen lost in life also
ein sack gesteckt der tür steht spielt
ob soll jetzt leute aber strikt nein
jetzt ist genug ist genug ich kann das
geht wirklich nicht weiter leute leute
mit sicherheit passieren in dieser folge
noch einige schlimme dinge aber ich kann
wirklich nicht weiter so das geht nicht
klar
es ist wirklich so schlimm ich habe ich
deswegen aber schaut euch mal die folge
verlinkt heute falls ihr das moment
machen wollt dann macht das meinetwegen
hier drüber so einfach ich persönlich
vorgeschlagen das video das wasser weit
von mir ich küsse augen
was zur hölle war das gerade eben